[Musique]
alors avant moi j'étais éducateur
sportif donc dans les yvelines
je bossais à lui à saint quentin en
yvelines à un club d'athlétisme et il
s'avère que quand j'étais au lycée
j'étais entre l'athlétisme le théâtre et
puis qui voit là j'ai passé un diplôme
d'éducateur sportif
j'ai travaillé pendant deux ans et après
j'avais envie de faire du théâtre
donc je suis parti à paris j'ai pris des
cours dans une école de théâtre privé
une école qui s'appelle artefacts et
puis voilà c'est un cursus de quatre ans
et puis voilà on a aussi de trouver des
projets de monter des projets avec des
copains de se trouver une petite famille
en collectif et qui ont fait des
castings on fait des rencontres
après voilà avec de la chance on trouve
un agent qui te pousse à faire des
castings et puis c'est mon agent
justement ces belles gaudin et ariel
leva qui c'est mais deux agents qui
m'ont dit vas-y tu tentes ta chance pour
les talents cannes adami tu as moins de
30 ans qui voit là j'ai été pris alors
j'ai tourné dans le film de cécile
telerman s'appelle shoegaze et pas du
tout c'est une poudre indienne en fait
quand tu l'as bois tu deviens sans
filtre enfin tu deviens toi même et donc
en fait l'histoire du court métrage
c'est ainsi speed dating est en fait on
a deux protagonistes de masques de deux
hommes qui rencontre de femmes et il
s'avère que les barmans lors de ce speed
dating mettre un petit peu de cette
poudre dans les verts et qui donc voilà
on voit les comédiens enfin les acteurs
pardon les personnages qui se lâche et
qui se passe des choses quoi tous ces
divorces dont tu t'occupes toute la
journée ça t'a pas donner envie de
rester célibataire
tu fais souvent les blacks
enfin des blagues qui font qu'ils font
rire je veux dire
quel bilan suffit de cette expérience
que j'ai envie de revenir
j'aimerais bien revenir défendre un film
et que ça va montrer qu'en fait c'était
possible vous pouvez petite porte qui
peut nous être ouverte voilà il faut
continuer à bosser et qu' il ya des gens
qui pensent un petit peu à l'avenir aux
jeunes et qui leur donne à des
possibilités de faire des courts
métrages de faire des films et de
travailler